it is important to realize that yes on
the one hand ideas are cheap and
everybody's got an idea and the hard
thing is follow through which takes a
lot more time and attention and so forth
but I think being Guided by these big
principles trying to do as the Mankind's
reach should exceed his grasp that's the
challenge that's what makes it so fun to
be a physicist when there are so many
different possibilities that you could
be right you could be wrong and and you
should have a humble form of swagger you
should know that you're probably wrong
but if you don't have a little Cockiness
you're never going to take on mother
nature you know she's just too powerful